ChatGPT最近偷偷開啟了一個超實用的功能
他把Photoshop整組搬進了ChatGPT里面
你沒有聽錯
就是那個大家都知道的PS
甚至完全能在ChatGPT裡面即時修圖
還在苦惱修圖的美編麻瓜
這期我們給他看下去
嗨各位又是我A
ChatGPT終於在年末的時候推出了一個讓人眼睛一亮的功能
應用程式 連接器是用ChatGPT調用外部的功能然後傳回ChatGPT
但是應用程式 則是可以在ChatGPT里面直接進行細節的調整
今天我們就來帶大家學會怎麽使用ChatGPT修圖吧
各位泛科學院跟YouTube learning Google for Education合作
推出一門完全免費的K12課程AI教學手札
我們講理論
而且有5位第一線擁有Google認證的老師直接示範
AI在真實的教學現場到底該怎麽用呢
到底怎麽樣省力
怎麽樣陪孩子學習
課程免費在泛科學院的YouTube觀看
完成測驗
還能夠取得YouTube learning還有Google for education的聯名證書
如果你不想在AI的時代被追著跑
而是想讓AI成為你的私人助教
這門課你真的可以現在就去看
首先我們要來到大家都已經很熟悉的ChatGPT登入後的主畫面
那在左邊的這個側邊欄里面
現在有一個新的選項叫做應用程式
那打開這個應用程式之後
你就可以在這個地方找到各種各式各樣的應用程式
那比如說我們今天
用的這個Adobe Photoshop在這邊然後點他
那如果你還沒有這個設定過的話 你要先做連線這個動作
然後你就選連線
連線
就連線完成
好那接下來你要怎麽樣用它
很簡單你可以直接在外面開始聊天但是你每次都要跑來這邊開始有點愚蠢
正常來說我們會直接在一個新的對話里面
你要呼叫PS出來很簡單你可以直接在按這個加號
加號里面 你可以找到一個更多 然後里面這邊就會有這個
Adobe Photoshop這個功能 那它會直接出現在這個地方
那另外一個方法是你可以按一下@ 就是按@之後他會有出現
所有你已經有聯動的一些相關的這APP 那你就可以選PS
有了這範例圖片之後呢
那我就可以跟他說
我要調整背景的顏色變成橘色
然後我們就直接按送出
那你只要看到有這個正在連接應用程式
就代表說ChatGPT他有理解你的指令需求
然後他去呼叫PS的這個應用程式那這樣就是成功的
那各位可以看到如果你有成功的驅動PS這個應用程式的話
他就會協助你幫你把你給他的這個圖片丟上去雲端
然後啟用必要的PS的這個功能讓你去做一些圖片的後製跟調整
而且下面他們還會告訴你說我要把背景改成橘色的話
他會給你這個色相 飽和度 自然飽和度 這兩個調整工具
那至於為什麽是這兩個工具
這就是AI會自動幫你選擇
所以你會根據不同的指令他會調用不同的Photoshop內建的那些修圖的工具
他下面會教你怎麽去使用這些工具 比如說我可以用這個
vibrance這個東西讓橘色更好看
那所以我就可以去找到比如說Vibrance這個工具
然後我就點一下這個選項的地方
他這邊會讓你去有一個可以拖曳的東西
那就會根據你的需求來去做一個調整
那如果你現在選擇這個模式呢
你會發現說我再去做這樣那個調整的時候
他其實是有幫助我去做原件的去背的這個動作
所以因為我的指令跟他說我要去調整背景的顏色
所以他就幫我把前景的人已經把我摳下來
那如果說剛剛這個地方調了之後調到一半或者該調都調完了
你就說有其他地方想要調整
接下來你可以直接在這個下面這邊有一個詢問Photoshop的這個對話框
他其實就跟我們在剛ChatGPT做這樣的一個連續性的這個對話一樣
就是我把背景調完了
那接下來我可能要調別的地方
比如說這個我要調整左邊女生的衣服顏色
然後我們這樣就按送出
好那跑完了之後
我們可以回去剛剛這個地方來我們說這個select object in image by prompt
好比如說select image
你看比如說左邊女生的衣服單獨選起來不會影響到背景其他人
那比如說進來之 呢你就可以直接單獨的去調整這個
衣服的顏色 根據你的喜好
那當然畢竟是Photoshop
我也可以要求他去加上一些不同的一些濾鏡的效果 等等的 比如說
加入不同的濾鏡跟特效好送出
applying effect
好關閉
好加了三種濾鏡特效
好那比如說我要用
lens distortion
這個是噪點
那這些東西就可以讓各位去慢慢的去做這樣的玩耍
那另外 就是我今天除了
開啟一些特殊的Photoshop的內建的那些功能
來去針對我的照片去做一些調整之外
那我也可以直接針對這張照片整體來去做自動化的調整
比如說我就一樣選一張新的照片傳上去
然後呢一樣開啟PS
然後跟他說比如說把我做成這個日系寫真的這種風格 然後我們就送出
所以這邊可以看到我如果跟他說我要做日系寫真
他一樣給了我這個柔光或者是顆粒這些相關的東西
然後去呈現那種底片風格那個時代那種照片的那種元素的形態
請幫我把這張圖片的景深變淺
所以可以自己去根據你的喜好來去做前景深一點點 去突出
第三招我怎麽知道要怎麽樣對這樣的一個PS的這個應用程式下指令
比如說我在網絡上
找到一張角色的圖片放上來
像這樣子的一個風格的圖片 那所以
我要把第一張圖用Photoshop改成第二張圖的色調跟光影
請給我一個Photoshop調整指南
注意 我這邊要的是請AI教我如何用Photoshop
你可以把你想象中的那一張理想的示範範例照片拿來
然後你把你的照片也傳上去所以這邊就不要開PS
因為我要的是製作的這個流程 ChatGPT就會幫你分析你的圖像
然後就會給你一個可以複製照作的這個PS的這個調色的這個流程好
那到這個地方呢
你會想說 嗯對
那就我們就照著這個東西來做
那這邊跟各位分享一個最近Google Chrome推出了一個小小的功能
你可以在這個分頁上面按一下右鍵
你會看到這個東西叫做將分頁加入新的分割畫面
所以就可以開這個好
在同一個分頁里面有兩個不同的網頁 好你看我這樣就有兩個GPT啦 所以呢
請協助我執行以下PS修圖指令 把這個地方複製上來
然後一按加上3個雙引號提供給他
3個雙引號 那旁邊的這些廢話我建議是刪掉這樣子好了就送出
我們一樣會呼叫了Photoshop這時候呢
你可以要求你的AI來去協助你去做到你想要調的那些東西
如果到這個地方
你覺得說這界面實在是太陽春了
那還有一招就是你可以直接按這邊open in Photoshop
他就會直接幫你把這張照片扔過去給Photoshop online
那這個應該也是上一個月最新推出的一個
這個免費的雲端版的Photoshop的這個功能
最後跟各位分享幾個我們在測試的時候的這個小小的心得
第一個這個Photoshop的這個應用程式的模式
不可以生成圖片
所以你要先準備好不管是用ChatGPT或是用其他的這些工具去生成的圖片
PS應用程式裡面他本質上只有修圖
那另外我們在測試的時候有發現
你可以透過upscale這個功能去把圖片的解析度把它向上提高
它是寫支援到8K的解析度了
但是我們自己測下來我們覺得大家到4K左右就已經差不多了
再上去就會有一點跑調
最後一個也就是最重要的
我們自己測試一天
在免費版的ChatGPT賬號大概會有2到3張的這個額度可以讓你去做使用
那如果你是付費版的ChatGPT的話
目前就我們測試下來還沒有遇過額度上限的提醒跟通知
好當然我也覺得這種東西就是會動態不斷的這個去做一些變化
以上就是我們今天這集的影片
歡迎你在影片下面留言跟我分享你的心得
那我們這集影片就到這個地方再見